sir how are you conan i am fine i am
fabulous
you love me i say you
look i've never seen more lighting on
one human being
what are you talking about i have one
little
little circular look at that little hold
it
there it is that's all i've got is that
little ring light that's all i have
no you look really good you do look
fantastic because you're what 82
or something you know because you've
been doing
this a long time i served our country
valiantly in the korean war
and i think i deserve credit for that
uh you look very nice you have a very
soft lighting
you look like uh barbara stanwick on the
big valley whenever they would share
with me
by the way i always love when you played
with the kids
the kids needed about barbra stanwick
and the big family
really here's a question i have people
ask me
this all the time and then i think me
what about
what about martin short people ask me do
you miss an audience and i think yeah i
miss an audience
marty short must really miss an audience
because you
you are a vaudevillian at heart you need
the laughter
look long ago i always worried about
what if something
happened and so i have an applause
record
and uh when i wake up i say how about
this morning
and i hit the button and i i don't know
i feel good it's better than vitamins
oh yeah yeah you're getting it yeah do
you really though do you really miss
because
i don't you know i strangely don't i
don't think i do
i'm obsessed with making sure that i do
everything right
for my children and myself and you know
i'm a new grandfather my son oliver and
daughter had a baby in january yeah so
you know making sure that everyone's
healthy and smart and doing things
correctly
and that kind of accomplishment is more
enticing to me than
your vaudeville need of uh
wait a second and all that stuff you do
with your kids
yeah i um i'm the opposite yes
i try to practice social distancing and
everything but i need the roar of the
crowd i never got laughs
was gonna say but you never got it so
why would you need it
when you need something wouldn't you
need something that you normally got
like this
you know i do very few sound effects
yeah but you are very good your cricket
is one of the best have you ever heard
my crow
let's hear your crowd
not bad you know i have one more
a monkey monkey
i just picture someone walking by a
house
right now in this quarantine
neighborhood
and you're alone in that house and say a
ups guy walking by and hearing that
and thinking well he's gone we've lost
him
no they just say i'm not going to that
house with wild monkeys
authentic wild monkeys and crickets
exactly are you
uh how do you handle since we brought it
up a package coming to the door
in the in these times some people are
very they don't want to take any
deliveries
a guy came up to me he's about you know
a younger guy he had a mask on
and he you know the glass and i said
just leave it on the porch and he looks
at me and goes
oh my god you're that guy
you're that guy you're martin short oh
yeah
hey i mean you got old but it's still
you
right he said that yeah
and then i said i said well um take off
your mask for a second i said how old
are you he said
i'm 34. i said i would have thought 40.
anyway
you got me dude
i'm an idiot
he's since been murdered don't worry i
don't care
i've been ravaged by time and it happens
look
it hasn't happened to me uh and nor will
it but yes
you have been ravaged ravaged you have
the hair care products that take care of
all that
this is a bunch of this is now i'm using
clay i'm using modeling clay
on my head doing whatever i can to keep
this thing going